like the whole freaking internet we also
can't get enough of miles tellers moves
thank you thank you we've all seen the
shimmy that's gone around the world and
now we're getting more in a never before
seen clip from top gun maverick
of course it's an homage to the og top
gun flick you know the scene miles
character rooster was just a kid sitting
on the piano as his dad goose tickles
the keys
[Music]
and now 36 years later rooster's all
grown up and recreating the special
moment he shared with his pops
[Music]
it was pretty exciting and just how
the the entrance into the bar is is very
uh it's very nostalgic but that
nostalgia meant added pressure for miles
who told et last month playing goose's
son came with responsibility for
somebody who's trying to follow in his
father's footsteps and somebody who
you know who's lost his dad at a very
young age there's a lot of heart in this
what rooster's dealing with is not what
you know goose was dealing with in the
original but yeah you want to you want
to make sure at times people can
you know see see goose
in there but i just thought it was a
really wonderful character and storyline
to play with with tom
and maverick and as we all know miles
does not disappoint fans cannot get
enough posting clips and images all over
social media specifically this clip
rooster showing off those moves and abs
on the beach
for that particular scene trying to live
up to the
you know the the homage of the the first
one the montage it was really
it was really
tough well miles you did it and you did
it so well the clips made it to
basically every corner online how does
this
turn into that cut my life into pieces
so naturally when e.t caught up with
miles recently we had to ask how he
feels about his explosive new wave of
fame
i've never really
experienced something like this in my
life
i you know tom before i signed on to
this he did he tried to lay out what it
would what it would be like and the
anticipation for this film and and how
how much fans you know really one
want this movie and how hard it was
going to be to satisfy him but just
based on the you know the reaction you
know we did it so it's just it's a
really good feeling goodness gracious we
want to sing and dance with rooster some
more
[Applause]
you